Oh guys I'm sorry I need to I need to
interrupt myself because look who just
walked up to me how did your presenting
though you guys were great we had a
really nice time up there together and
I'm getting one single rose from a rose
of a girl hi Kristin I was fine in that
moment before we came out I'm standing
with Kristin and Maya he's not gonna
take the camera off and putting on
flowers totally interrupted I don't mind
people call his wig Dolph Dolph I felt
like the I felt like your bid was
received very well I hope so I hope
wieners went over okay for Plummer and
James Earl Jones how do you feel about
it I I can't tell when I'm up there it's
like I you never know do you allow
yourself to listen or do you have to
just be in the moment and not and just
try to drown everybody else out block
them out be in the moment I think
because if you if you hear especially
something that's you think is gonna get
a laugh and it doesn't you get these
little sweat things that come down
you know what can I just be really
shameless here for a second and tell
everybody watching that you guys have a
movie another movie coming out in a
couple weeks that's really great it's
called friends with kids friends with
kids directed by Jen Westfeldt and and
starring Jon Hamm and you guys and Adam
Scott who's amazing and it's really
funny so people should go see it because
it comes out in like two weeks or so
making his way making its debut this is
the Morris Lessmore this is the Morris
Lessmore winners congratulations yeah
anyway well thanks for coming by and
talking about I'm not going to like okay
Sherri Shepherd Cameron Mathison eat
your hearts out I just got a rose just
saying Oh Kristin saying hi